Hey everyone here on the freeCodeCamp channel. In this tutorial,
I'm going to be building a tool
that every app on startup should
have. I'm going to build a
dashboard to let you know if
your app is down. And if it does
notify you via email and SMS. So
in other words, it clone of the
popular software as a service
app pager duty. My name is Ania
Kubow and I'm a course creator
here on freeCodeCamp, as well
as on my own channel. And I'm
going to be your guide to this
wonderful tutorial on building
this platform here today. One of
the best ways to learn software
development is to create a
slimmed down version of software
you use every day to get a
better understanding of how it
might work. This process helps
you understand the problem space
constraints and techniques
required to build a real world
use case pager duty is awesome
as it helps alert teams to high
priority incidents like web
outages or security issues using
pre configured configuration
strategies, and multi channel
notifications. In this tutorial,
we will recreate some of the key
components of this application
using JavaScript for our
application logic. Postgres is
store our data, results of other
user interface and back end
workflows. And finally Twilio to
power SMS notification as well
as SMTP. By the end of this
tutorial, you will be able to
create data structures and
Postgres to feed into your
application. This will include
creating an incidence table as
well as team members table, we
will then feed this data into
our UI so we can see it and
interact with it. So as you will
see here under the incidents
tab, and the team members tab,
that we are bringing back all
that data. The Team Members tab
will also help us see who is
working on what, as well as
their shift times so that we can
tell who is on call. And when we
will also then be able to see
all the incidents that are
currently acknowledged and being
worked on, as well as filter
them down to just the ones
assigned to a specific user. We
will add functionality to bring
up data if we click on specific
rows, and much more, we will
also add the ability to add team
members from the interface as
well as add in new incidents via
the interface as well as delete
a team member or delete an
interface. So bunch of stuff
going on here. And finally, we
will hook up Twilio and SMTP. So
that we can send email
notifications and SMS
notifications to our team
members in case the website
theoretically goes down. This
video is created thanks to a
grant from resource, the local
solution for building internal
tools and platforms. So what are
we waiting for? Let's do it.
Okay, so let's do it. First off,
I'm just going to create a new
app. So I'm just going to go
ahead and click on here. And I'm
going to call this pager duty
club. Okay, and click create the
app. So there we go, we've just
created our app, essentially,
this is essentially our work
zone. And I'm going to start off
by just dragging in some UI in
order to make it look like a
pager duty clone. So the first
thing I'm going to do is
actually just drag in some tabs
containers, as we're gonna have
two tabs here, one to view the
incidents, and one to view all
our team members. So let's make
that reflect here. We can also
rename this actual UI component.
So I can call it main tabs if I
wish. Okay, great. And I'm here,
I'm just going to change this to
say incidents.
And this one to say team
members. So we are literally
just creating our tabs
container, just like so. We can
of course, also change the
colors of this. So if you just
highlight the whole UI
component, and then go down
here, I can choose the header
background color, I can choose
the footer background color, or
I could just choose the
background, I'm going to go
ahead with Canvas to make it
much the background that we
have.
Okay, and if we wanted a little
darker, we can also choose our
own custom color. So for
example, I could do hex E, E, E,
or just three E's for short. And
that will also be applied.
Wonderful. To get rid of the
third view that we are not going
to be using simply just go ahead
and click on here and delete it
from view. So there we have it,
one view and a second view. We
can also personalize the actual
selected colors. So I'm gonna go
with green for now as I think it
looks better. Okay. Wonderful.
Now, under
incidents, what do we want to
show? Well, we should probably
have some kind of header, right.
So let's go ahead and select a
text option, we're going to have
a simple text, or we're going to
have a text area, or rich text
editor, or even editable text,
I'm just going to go ahead and
select the text option. And we
can even choose if we would like
to use HTML elements to kind of
decide how big each of the text
elements are going to be. So I
can have incidents on all teams
as a title, just like so. And
it's styled like an h1 element
title. If you wanted to give a
custom styling to this h1
element, that is also possible,
okay, all you would have to do
is go to scripts and styles and
add in some custom CSS for this
whole document. We are not going
to be doing that now. But I just
thought it was worth giving you
a sneak peek at that. Next up,
what do I want? Well, we can
have dividers to kind of
separate out everything in here.
So I'm going to in fact, use a
divider to separate the title
from the table that we are going
to input. Now let's put in a
table. So our table at the
moment is not going to mean
much. Okay, it's just going to
have some dummy data in there.
So there is some dummy data
that's being fed in, we're going
to delete all of this as we're
going to use some actual data
from a Postgres database that we
are going to make. So just leave
that blank for now. In the
meantime, I'm also just going to
drag in some text to go below
here. And I'm going to use the H
five element this time, so a
smaller header
to say, your open incidents
and then just drag in some more
texts, so that we can actually
see those incidents. For now I'm
going to put zero triggered and
make this red.
So the text is going to be
danger. And then just copy and
paste that. And this time, this
is going to be to show our
acknowledged incidents.
And I'm going to change this
color to be info.
Okay,
wonderful. So there's a lot you
can do with styling with this
text, I'm going to leave it like
that for now. And we're going to
choose this number dynamically
based off our you guessed it,
our database. So in fact, I'm
just going to copy this and
paste it because we're going to
drag this over to the right and
see all our open incidents as
well. So we've got your open
incidents, let's also have all
open incidents. And again, we're
going to feed that number in
dynamically on component text
seven, and component text five.
Great.
Now I'm going to add a button,
this button was clicked, it's
going to help us add a new
incident to our database. So we
can actually do that from our
UI, which is kind of cool. And
this button, we can style it up.
So I can have an incident if I
wish. And let's make this blue,
green just to match the rest of
this board. And I can even
choose to make it a little bit
bigger. Next, I'm just going to
use a container to contain a
bunch of stuff that I want to
add next. So I'm just going to
put that in here like so for
now. And this time, in fact, I'm
going to get rid of the header.
So we can do that, we can select
the whole UI component, and then
I can choose to hide the header.
So at the moment, we're just
showing the body if you wanted
to show footer, then you can do
that. That is totally up to you.
Okay, wonderful. So we have one
container, I'm actually going to
have to so I'm just going to
drag in another one right below
here. Okay, so that we go. This
one again, I don't want to have
a header showing, so I'm just
going to hide it now and the
first one, we're going to just
display who is on call. So I'm
going to just have the title
here of encore. Okay, and I'm
just going to make it green. So
I'm going to change the color to
be green of the text. We can
also make it bold if we wish.
Okay, so I'm just going to use a
opening and a closing tag for
that to make that bold. That
name next thing I'm going to
drag in is a place to actually
display whoever is currently on
call. So for now I'm just going
to put x x x as we don't really
know who's on call yet.
because, once again, we're going
to get that from our database.
So I'm just going to also make
sure that it's an h3 element,
just like that, just to make
sure it's a bit bolder. And we
can even use an avatar. So I can
just drag in a premade
component. That's right, that
will show us our avatar. At the
moment. Again, this is just
based off my information, my
user detail, I'm the current
user of this app. But we will
over write this. So in fact,
just so I don't forget to do
this, I'm just going to put x x
x for all of these so that we
don't forget to add that in
dynamically. Great. Now, we can
put a divider or we can add a
footer is totally up to you.
Let's choose to add a footer.
And in the footer, here, I'm
going to add some more
information, I'm going to drag
in a text component, just like
so. And here, I'm going to put
in a bolt you are on call for.
And once again, this is going to
be fed dynamically, I'm going to
essentially create a list of
tags. So we can find these tags
in here too. And I'm just going
to put them in below. Just like
sir. Okay, so that's going to
display what we as the person on
call on call for. In here,
again, I'm just going to drag in
some more tax, this is going to
say and called on call. Now.
Let's go ahead and make this
color green. And here, we're
just going to list out all the
incidents that we are currently
on call for.
Okay, so I'm going to exercise
for now as that will be fed
dynamically. And we're also
going to show the shift of the
current person that is on call.
So it's really obvious.
I'm going to put once again and
fold your shift,
and then close this tag.
And then actually display the
two shift times as well as some
contact information. So this is
going to be from, we're going to
put our starting time of the
shift, and this is going to be
two and we're going to put the
end time of the shift of the
current person on call. And
here, I'm just going to put some
information like contact.
And then I'm going to put info
at
Free Code camp.org as well
pretending business free code
camps pager duty app to make any
changes to your shift.
Okay, wonderful. So that's
really it.
Okay, so that's for showing all
the incidents. Of course, we
haven't hooked this up to any
data quite yet. Let's work on
the team members tab next. So
just like with the team members
tab, in fact, what I'm going to
do is so super simple, I'm just
going to copy this, I'm going to
copy the divider, we're going to
copy the button. And I'm also
going to copy this container
and click Command C. And inside
here, I'm just going to paste it
in. Okay, so it looks kind of
similar. We're going to change
this title to say, team members,
okay. And on the Add incident
button, well, I'm going to put
add, new team member, of course,
as this is dealing with team
members. And in here, well,
let's just delete that we don't
really want that, I'm just going
to show the selected team member
from the table that we're going
to have, we're not going to have
an avatar. So let's delete that
we're not going to have your own
code for instead, we're going to
have a signed operations. So we
can see the assigned operations
that are there for the user.
Okay, so there we go, we have
the same operations that will be
viewed as a tag list. And I'm
also going to put in the shift
dates for the user we are
selecting.
OK, so once again, in bold, I'm
just going to put shift dates
and close that off.
Okay, and once again, let's just
put from
two
and then I'm also going to put
the evil of the person that we
want to contact.
Okay, so our emails gonna go.
Great.
Now one small is also dragging a
table, as this is going to show
all our team members from what
you guessed, our Postgres
database. So let's go ahead and
delete all that data. That is
some fake data that has been
passed through
And finally, outside of the
incidents and outside of the
members, so outside of this
whole tab container, I'm going
to have another container. Okay,
so I'm going to put in a
container. In fact, let's make a
form, as essentially, we are
going to be sending something
from here, we're gonna be
sending an email. Okay. So there
we go, there is an email form
for us. And I'm just going to
put email
composer, as that is what I want
to build, let's make the title
of this the header, I'm going to
change the color of the header.
So if we find the header
background, I'm just going to go
with highlight as the color of
choice. And let's change the
Submit button to I'm going to
make a warning. Okay, and in
here I'm going to put to send
to, and then whoever we are
highlighting from the team
members is going to be the
person to receive this email. So
that is going to be quite cool.
And another thing we can do is
use the rich text editor. So now
we get a whole rich text editor
component, this is pretty cool.
Okay, imagine trying to code
that out yourself. And in here,
we're going to put Hi, and we're
just going to put the selected
user from our table.
So that's it. That's what we
have built so far. Now let's get
to linking all of this up. So
for this tutorial, I'm going to
use a render.com lynda.com is
essentially a way for us to host
our database in a non paid way.
Okay, so please go ahead and
just go to the dashboard, sign
up, go to the dashboard. And we
are going to sign in, I'm going
to just choose to sign in with
Google. Okay, so please choose
your own way of signing in, it's
up to you. And once he actually
need to click on New, and it's a
Postgres database that we are
going to be create that is
hosted on render, I'm going to
call this pager duty as that's
what I'm creating this database
for, I'm happy for the database
to be randomly generated, as
well as the user name. And we're
just going to select the free
tier and click create database.
Okay, so it really was that easy
that is creating. In the
meantime, I'm gonna go here and
go to resources. So let's go
ahead and create a new resource
is going to be a Postgres SQL
database, I'm just going to call
it pager duty, as that will be
easy for us to find the host.
Well, that is this. So I'm just
going to copy this host name,
like so. But then I'm also going
to
have to append
dot Oregon
postgres.render.com. So just
make sure to append that keep
the port as 5432. As you see
here, the database name is pager
duty. So let's put that in here.
And as authentication, we're
going to use the database
username, which is this, and the
database password. So here's the
password, please go ahead and
use your own because this one
will not work after this
tutorial is. So there we go. I'm
going to click connect using
SSL. And let's just test this
works. And connection is a
success. This is because we left
the address, IP address as
everywhere, okay. But if you
wanted to, you know, keep it
kind of private, you might
consider adding these IP
addresses. So great. Let's
create a resource.
Let's go back to the resources.
And now I'm just going to shut
that down and refresh this. So
it loads the latest resources.
And I'm going to choose pager
duty as my resource name, that's
just the one I made. Okay, so
I'm actually going to use this
UI in order to add the actual
tables that I'm going to use for
this project. Okay, so I'm going
to just go ahead and create my
first table. So I'm going to use
the Create Table command. And
I'm going to create a table of
incidents. Okay, so get up your
parenthesis and let's define
what's going to go on our table.
Well, I'm going to put an ID,
which is going to take an
integer value, I'm going to put
an urgency level which is just
going to take our chart 30. So
30 characters, essentially, I'm
going to have triggered Is this
a triggered event? Well, it's
yes or no. So I'm gonna have a
Boolean for this.
Next, I'm also gonna have
acknowledged, this will also be
a Boolean,
as well as resolved, which is
also going to be a Boolean. Next
we're going to have a
description of the actual
incident itself. So that's going
to take
bar char. And I'm going to
actually limit that to 30. Okay,
we don't want them to be too
long, and then assigned to, and
this is going to take an
integer. In fact, it's going to
take the ID of a an employee.
And I'm also going to have a
created
date, which is gonna take a
date. So that's what my table
looks like, don't forget to
finish it off with some semi
colons. Let's check if this
works, I'm going to click Save
and Run. And great, that seems
to have worked, we haven't got
any errors. And we're gonna call
this playground for now, as I'm
essentially using this as a
little mini playground to add
our tables. Okay, so that was
one thing that we have done, you
can keep this in here, if you
wish. In fact, I'm just going to
comment that out. Because I'm
going to create a new table to
create
table team, this is going to
take our team. So what's our
team going to be made up of?
Well, each team member is going
to have an ID, which I'm going
to say has to be an integer,
they're going to have a first
name, which I'm going to take as
virtuoso characters, let's just
do 30. Again, a last name, which
I'm going to be super strict
about this too. Of course, you
don't have to have 30, I'm just
choosing to for now. And an
email, var char binders put 225
wide dots, okay, you can have
higher character numbers, if you
wish. Next, I'm going to have a
phone number of your team mate,
which is going to be an integer
value, and Avatar, which is
actually going to be a URL to an
image on the internet. And then
we're going to have on call to
check if they're on court or
not. And this is going to be a
boolean value, as well as a
shift,
start. And that's going to be a
date,
a shift and value, which is also
going to be a date, and
incidents that they are working
on, which is going to be text,
but it's also going to be an
array of texts. So that's how I
would write that. Great. And
just finish off some semicolons.
And hit save and run. So there
we go, we have just added our
table for team members. So I'm
just going to comment that out.
I'm going to go ahead and just
add two incidents just to start
off with just so we have stuff
to play around with. So I'm
going to insert into the table
called incidents.
And we're going to insert an ID
and urgency value a triggered
value, an AK, knowledge value,
resolved value or description
assigned to
making sure to spell it exactly
the same as we did up here.
created date. And that should be
it. So those are the values we
want to insert into let's
actually get the values. So the
value for the ID, I'm going to
put incident ID number one,
we're going to put urgency as
the string of high as well as
the triggered is going to be
true. Technology is going to be
true and resolved is going to be
false. So we've put in Boolean
values for those. And now I'm
just going to put in a
description of this incident,
it's going to be DevOps
escalation.
So just like that, it's going to
be assigned to the employee with
ID 201. And then we're just
going to put in a date that this
was created at, I'm going to put
a date in the past, okay,
because, you know, we don't want
to put everything as today's
date. So there we go. Okay, and
don't forget to finish the off
with a semi colon. Okay, so
there is our semicolon, and just
hit save and run.
Great. And that has run
successfully. So that is one
incidence, let's just add a
another one. This one is going
to have the value of two. Let's
put the
urgency as low. Let's add true,
maybe false false, this time for
triggered, acknowledged and
resolved. This one can be called
Security ops.
S escalation making sure to
spell security correctly. It's
going to be assigned to use a
201 as well. And let's put this
as maybe one day
earlier. I'm click Save and Run.
Great. And I'm just going to
comment that out. I am now just
going to insert into team so I'm
only going to insert one person
into here i
Pick, that will be fine, we need
to get the ID, we also get the
first name of the person we are
inserting, and the last name
making sure this will exactly
the same as we have in this
table. Next up is email.
Next up is the phone number.
Next up is the Avatar. And I'm
going to have on call.
It's up shift
starts
shift and, and the incidence
attached to them. Once again,
just making sure that everything
is spelled correctly, because
next we're going to put in the
values. And the value of this,
well, this is going to be team
number 201, the name is going to
be Ania. And their last name is
going to be Kubo. Now my email
address, I'm just going to put
as the string of Ania at Free
Code camp.org.
The phone number, I'm just going
to put a fake phone number for
now.
And as my avatar Well, I'm just
going to use my avatar from Free
Code Camp. So please make sure
to take an image that you know
is unlikely to be taken offline,
or alternatively store them
yourself on imager.com. Or you
can put them on an external
database such as AWS, for
example.
So I'm just going to copy this
image address. And I'm just
going to paste it in like so.
Now after the avatar, I'm just
going to specify if this person
is on call, I'm going to put
true. And then I'm going to also
put a made up start shift time,
a made up and shift time as a
string,
and then an array. So we can
literally just put the word
array like so. And then I'm
going to put in dev ops, s
collation.
And security ops, a skull
escalation as the incidents
assigned to this user. Okay,
don't forget to end it with some
semicolons, hit save and run it
say integer out of range, that's
fine, I'll just change the
format of the folder.
And now I'm going to add in that
Twilio phone number making sure
to add 001 at the front and hit
Run and safe. Now it does say
that integer out of range, which
is kind of strange, I don't
think this should be out of
range. But that is fine, we
might have to make this a string
instead. So let's go ahead and
make that a string, I'm actually
going to just comment this out,
we're going to drop the table
DROP TABLE team. So essentially,
we're going to delete it,
because we have to change the
data type of the phone number.
So make sure to drop that. And
now I can create a table again.
So this is good for anyone who
perhaps made an error in the
first place. And I'm just going
to change this to var char as
well. So that will not take a
string. So save that and run it
to create this table again, with
the number of being an email.
And now we can insert into Tim,
after you have commented this
out. So save and run.
And great. We have now added our
first team member, so I'm just
going to comment this out for
now.
Okay, so that was our
playground. And now I'm going to
get some data that we can feed
in into our first table of all
the incidents. So let's create a
new resource. And let's make
sure that the result is pager
duty. I'm just going to do
select all from the table
incidents. And click Save and
Run. Let's see what that looks
like. And indeed, we get two
incidents back. I'm going to
rename this get incidents as
that is essentially what this
query does. And now in here,
instead of adding data manually,
I can get incidents and get the
data of those incidents so that
it feeds in there and it's
automatically mapped out to
these lovely table rows. What is
cool is if you want to see the
whole data object that comes
back, you can all you have to do
is go to state and get the
incidents and there's the data
and you will see all that
information as
The arrays that we can use.
Okay, so that's just in this tab
on the left here, I'm just going
to minimize that left panel now.
So that's what I have done.
Let's carry on working on this.
So another cool thing we can do
is actually adjust which kind of
columns do you want to see or
edit or anything like that. So
for example, I can choose to
hide the description if I want.
So I'm just going to select the
whole table. And I'm going to
choose to hide the description
by pressing on this little irate
here, I'm also going to hide the
assigned to, I'm going to keep
the created date. And I can even
if I want, add a new column, add
a custom column. And this column
is going to help me delete
incidents if I want. So at the
moment, I'm not really going to
put anything in here apart from
just decide that it's going to
be a button. Okay, that is my
button. And the value of this is
just going to say, delete. So
there we go, we can of course,
make the columns smaller if we
wish, and just in general, play
around with this a little bit
better. So I'm happy with this
table. Let's now change the
value of this hard coded zero.
And I can do so easily, I can
literally get the incidence
data. And I can look inside to
see how many of the objects
triggered are true, right. So
for this, I'm going to use the
filter method. And I'm going to
look through each item, okay, by
essentially filtering through
each one, and used AI as the
representation of each item that
we are filtering. And if i
equals true, I'm going to get
the length of that array. So as
you will see here, two incidents
are triggered. And if we look
here, indeed, two incidents are
triggered. So if we do the same
for acknowledge, we should get
one acknowledged incident. So
let's try again, we'll use the
two curly braces as that is how
we do things in retool in order
to get values from the queries.
So the query we wrote is called
Get incidents, right. So I'm
essentially getting the name of
whatever we called this query
and getting the data from it.
And I am going to this time
filter by the acknowledged, so
I'm going to get acknowledged
and use the filter method on it
to essentially filter and if I
or each item in that array
equals true, I'm going to get
the whole arrays length. And
indeed, we get a one. So once
again, curly braces, in order to
access data from the queries,
the query I wanted to access is
the get incidents query, you can
see all the information that
comes back here. And again, if
you really want to see the whole
object, we can look in here. So
I've got incidents I've got into
the data object, then I've gone
into the acknowledged array, and
I filtered out anything that is
equal to true and got the length
of that array.
Got it? Cool.
Okay, so to do your open
incidents, we're going to have
to do something else, because
we're going to actually have to
get the user. Okay, so perhaps
let's do that next. Now, who was
the user? Well, I think the user
should be whoever's on call,
right. So let's go ahead and
create a new resource query, I'm
going to call this get user. And
I'm going to select all from
team this time. So the table of
team were on call equals true,
I'm going to save and run this.
So there we go, it comes back
with one user and at all points,
we really should only have one
person on call, right. So that
is a kind of rule that should be
done in the backend, this isn't
a front end thing. So we can
just assume that this will come
back with one user at all times.
So that is going to be a user.
And I'm going to filter
incidents by the user. So let's
try another resource. I'm going
to write filter incidents.
And I'm going to select all,
from incidents.
were assigned
to equals and then I'm just
gonna get the user data. So this
is our get user query. We're
going to get the ID but only
going to get the first ID from
the array because we are
assuming there is only one so
that should be fine. And don't
forget your semicolons at the
end, so
I'm just going to save and run
that. And making sure to spell
incidents there correctly. Just
run that again. Okay, so two
items come back. This is because
indeed, two items are assigned
to me and your Kuba because my
user ID is 201. Great. Once we
get to adding more incidents in
here, you will see how that
changes. So now that means I can
use my filter incidents query to
dynamically update these. So
once again, use our curly
braces, filter incidence is the
query I want to use, I want to
get the data from it. And I want
to get the triggered.
array. And I want to filter it
based on if I have the item in
here in this array equals true,
and I want to get its length.
Okay, so to will be triggered,
that is correct, because I'm
just going on my open incidents.
And other moment, I'm the only
user in here. So once again, you
guessed it, we're gonna get the
curly braces, we're gonna get
the filtered incidents. So let's
get the filter incidents data.
And this time, we're going to
get the acknowledged array and
filter it by looping over i and
if i equals true, we're going to
get to the length of this array
at the end. Wonderful. So this
is all looking good. We can now
actually also fill out this
because we aren't technically
getting the user. So we can use
this query, let's run it again
and see what it looks like to
find out who's on call, right?
So I can use my curly braces, to
go into the get user query and
get the data and get the first
name that comes back to us.
Okay, so I'm going to get the
first name. And I could also put
the second name, I've literally
just put a space there, this
will work, I'm going to get user
data.
Last Name, great. And same for
the avatar, well, I'm going to
get user data,
Avatar at this time, and just go
into the first item of that
array. Same for the email. So on
the label here, I'm just going
to get into get user data to the
email
and get the first item from the
array.
In fact, maybe we should have
that on the actual caption of
the label. And here, we will
just have the first name again.
So I'm just going to take all of
this
and whack it onto the label
here.
We can also essentially map out
what the tags are. And here
we're going to get the
incidents, right, so let's get
rid of that curly braces, get
user data incidents. And we're
gonna have to go into the first
item, that array. And there we
go. So these incidents have now
been mapped out onto here.
Great. Let's also do the same
for here. So I'm just going to
show all the incidents, I'm
going to get the user data
incidents.
And actually, if I treat this as
an element, we can actually just
put the array in here like so.
Okay, so that's something I have
done.
Now, from here, I'm just gonna
get into the user again data and
get the
shift start.
And once again, on here, I'm
going to get user data, this
time shift, and great. So we've
populated all of that base of
the get user query. How cool is
that? Next up was work on adding
an incident. So for this, I'm
actually going to create a modal
that's going to pop up. So in
fact, let's go ahead and just
put that up here. And I'm just
going to delete this button. So
delete it, and I'm going to
change the text of this to be
add incident.
Let's also change it to be
green. So I'm just going to
minimize that for now. As well
as the state. The accent
background is going to be green.
We're just going to make it a
little bit bigger.
Okay, so that is our modal.
And here I'm just going to put
in some tags. So I'm going to
drag in some texts, and this is
going to say add incident. I'm
going to make this an h2
element, add
incident
Just like so
let's also put a divider, I'm
going to put that in right down
here.
And then I'm going to create a
number input. So one
specifically to put in numbers.
So just like that with a label
in incident ID.
Great. Next, I'm going to create
a drop down. So I'm going to
have this select drop down, just
like so. And I'm going to put
the value of the label as
urgency. And I'm going to hard
code my options, option one is
going to be high, option two is
going to be medium. And option
three is of course going to be
low. So those are my options.
And if you leave the label as
empty, it will just take the
value as the default. And I'm
happy with that.
Next, I'm just going to create
some
switches. So this is because I'm
going to be dealing with Boolean
values, so I'm fine with this,
I'm going to have one for
triggered.
Let's also have one for
acknowledged.
And finally, let's have one for
resolved.
Okay, so those are my three
options right? There. You can of
course, start them up as much as
you want.
Next, we're going to have a
description input. So for this,
I think we should just have some
text. So I'm going to put in a
text input. This is why I kept
the description short, Max 30
characters, because you know,
that's not a lot to work with.
And we can also cap this as
well. So we can cap the value.
You can have a max length of 30,
just like so. And let's go ahead
and put description
here.
And finally, let's have one more
select drop down. So select. And
here, we're going to select who
this is assigned to. So I'm
going to put assigned to.
And instead of having options,
I'm going to map out the
options, this time, the data
source for this, well, we're
going to have to get all the
team members, right, so let's go
ahead and write a new query, I'm
going to call this get team and
we're gonna get all the team
members. And the query for this
is select all from Team and run
it. So that's going to be the
data source, get team. And
that's going to auto populate
for you. And great, this is
fantastic is exactly what I
want.
Okay, so now we can actually
choose which team member to
select in such a nice way. Okay,
and whichever one we select,
it's actually going to pick out
the ID of that item. So if I
select me, the value of this,
when it's selected will be 201.
So readable, and then practical.
Great. And finally, I'm just
going to put in a button,
that's going to submit this
modal.
So I'm just going to put Summit,
and we can actually make the
height of this Moodle dynamic
based on what's inside. So I can
do hug content, and then that
will happen. Okay, wonderful.
Now let's write a query for
adding an incident. So add
incident, just like so making
sure the resource is pager duty.
And once again, we're
essentially going to use this
piece of code. So I'm just going
to copy all of that, because
that is the code that we will
need in order to add a new
incident, of course when it's
uncommented out. So that's what
we are going to insert into the
table incidents. However, this
time the values will not be hard
coded. They will in fact be
taken from here. So I'm going to
use my curly braces to access
this component which is called
number input one number input
one and get its value. If you
hover over that you will see
that zero well if I change this
that will change and you will
see the value is now two
Okay, so as literally getting
the value of that input, this
second one is the urgency,
right. And this component is
called select one. So I'm going
to gret select one and get its
value once more. So if I choose
high, that will now be high.
Wonderful. So hopefully that's
kind of making sense. Next,
we're going to go on these
switches. So that is going to be
switch one, two, and three. So
once again, I'm just gonna use
my curly braces to get switch
ones value, switch, two's value,
as long as these are of course
in the correct order. And then
switch threes value switch,
three, value. And finally, I'm
just going to minimize this, we
need to get the description
which is text input one, and the
Select to value. So description
is going to go here. And that is
text input value one, I believe,
yes, text input one and select
two.
So select to value, and we're
just going to get today's date.
So I'm going to use the new date
object from JavaScript to do
that, once again, make sure it's
in curly braces, and just call
it. So that's what I've done,
I'm essentially getting the
values of all these inputs,
let's have a go at filling this
out. So let's go Incident Number
three, urgency, high triggered,
acknowledge, not resolved
description, well, I can go
ahead and put anything I want,
let's put
deployment.
And assigned to what I'm the
only one here right now. So
great. And now this button,
well, we need to trigger the Add
incident query we just wrote. So
I'm going to add an event
listener control query that's
been generated for me at
incidents because I'm currently
on that query. And we're going
to trigger that. Okay, that
looks great to me. So now,
before I submit this, I'm going
to run this query with all these
values filled out, you will see
the values that we are
essentially going to put,
they've all been now filled out.
And if this works, well on
success actually want to do a
few things, right, I want to get
all the incidents again. So the
freshest incidents, and I also
want the modal to close. So I'm
going to control a component to
this time. And that component is
the modal. So let's go ahead and
find it. And I want it to close,
we can also add some other fun
things like confetti if we want.
So confetti, let's go ahead and
do that. And save. So I haven't
run this because I want to
trigger it by pressing this
button. So I'm going to click on
here,
we have got an error, let's
debug.
It would seem I just put a extra
string, I didn't delete those
strings properly. So now let's
save. Let's try it again. And
hit submit. And great that has
worked. And tada, we have gotten
the fresh incidents again. And
that has updated our table. So
this is looking great. And you
will see that this has been
updated to
oh, this has not been updated.
That's because we of course also
need to run the filter incidents
method as well. So on success of
adding an incident, let's add
the gets filtered incidents
also. Okay, so there we go. Now
I've just run that again. So we
would have added the same stuff
again, because as you will see,
that information is still there.
So now let's work on deleting
that third one, okay, because we
don't want it but at least we
know this is working. And this
is working and everything is
updating. So now let's work on
it deleting an incident. So this
one I'm going to call delete
incident.
The resource is going to be
pager duty, and all I'm going to
do is delete from incidents
where ID equals and then this is
table one selected row.
Data it so this for the either
it is going to cause a problem.
This is because you know, if we
essentially delete, this one is
going to look at the ID and it's
going to delete both of these.
So just keep in mind that
whenever you add an incident
that Id needs to be unique. So
save that and onsuccess of this
well once again, I'm going to
essentially get all the
incidents
and run
The filter incidents query once
more. So let's save that. And
now let's hook up this button to
that. So let's find that custom
button that we made an on click,
we're going to run a query, and
that query is delete incident.
Okay, so that's what we want to
happen. Now let's try it out.
I'm going to click Delete
incident. And that should delete
and it's deleted all of these
incidents, and it's gotten all
the incidents again, so we can
view them in the table. And it's
updated these based on the
filter incident query and the
get incident query. Wonderful.
So I'm really happy with this.
Let's carry on. Okay, now it's
time to move on to the team
members page. So in here, let's
go ahead and use the get team
query in order to populate this
table. So once again, I will use
my curly braces, get the get
team query and the data from it.
And that should automatically
update my table right here.
Again, we can choose which
columns to hide, so I'm going to
hide the avatar column, this
time, I'm going to hide the
phone number, I'm also going to
hide the start shift and the end
shift as well as the incidence,
okay, and I'm going to add a
custom column once again, to be
able to delete that user. So
this is going to be a button. So
let's go ahead and do that.
So there we go, there is a
button that says, delete after
we update the value. So great.
Before we go deleting anything,
let's populate this container
with this selected user, as well
as add functionality to add a
new team member. So to do this,
I'm actually going to rename
this component, as I mentioned,
this is something you can do. So
I'm just going to call it team
table. Okay. And that just makes
it more reasonable for when I
use this table. So the team
table, so I can literally use my
curly braces, to access the team
table component
and get the selected row data.
And I could just grab the first
name, if I wish of that selected
row. And of course, I could do
so for the last name too. So
once again, that's going to
Bacardi braces. And I'm just
going to use 10 tables selected
row data. Last Name, this time.
And Wonderful. Great, we can
also use the avatar that I have
hidden from the table, but it
still does exist. So if I want
to just go ahead and grab an
image,
just like so.
And now I can go into the team
table on small selection of data
and get the avatar as that
exists. On here, even though
it's a deleted column. Once
again, if you want to have a
look at the objects for this,
just have a look in here look at
get team data. And we're getting
the selected row data, right
avatar.
And that is the URL that I am
getting.
Great. And now let's populate
these other components. So here
once again, I would delete all
that would use the team table
selected row data to get the
array of incidents that will be
mapped out onto these tags. And
you know what to do this should
be easy. Now once again, let's
go into the team table selected
row data and get the shift start
time. And then also get this
shift and time. So team table,
select data,
shift and is what I want. And
here I'm just going to display
the email address. So once
again, Team table selected or
data dot email. Wonderful. And
that was it very painless. Now
let's get to adding a new team
member. So for this, I'm
actually going to use the modal
components. I'm just going to
put that in here for now and
it's delete this button.
So I'm just going to delete that
and move this over. So move over
the modal button
just to here. It's going to make
it a little bit bigger. And of
course we can style it up. I'm
just going to make everything
green. And then it's changed the
font of this to be add new team
member.
Great. So now let's work on the
modal
So for this, I'm just going to
drag in some text, let's make
this an h3 element. And it's
gonna say add a new team member.
Just like that. And I'm just
going to drag it out, I'm also
going to have another divisor
just like we did previously. So
I can put that divide it in
right here.
And then let's add some inputs.
So I'm going to put a number
input.
And this is going to say, Team
Member ID. So let's change the
text of the label to say, Team
Member ID. Let's also just have
a text input, this is going to
be for the first name. And we're
gonna also have one for the last
name, too. So let's change this
to say, first name.
And I'm literally going to copy
and paste. So the second one
shows up. So I can change this
to last name, we're also going
to have email. So there is a
special email input we can use.
So there we go, I'm just going
to drag that in like so and put
it here.
Maybe let's put some two dots
there, just so we can make it
look the same. And then we're
going to have a phone number.
Well, this is actually a text
input as we know, because we
changed that to be a text input.
So I'm just going to put phone
number like
that.
And it's also an avatar image.
Well, this is just going to be a
URL to something on the
internet, as we mentioned, for
now, of course, you don't have
to have it like that, you can
link this up to an AWS database
if you wish in order to store
images. Next, we need to have a
checkbox to allow us to check if
someone's on call or not. Okay,
so let's go ahead and put on
call here, and then someone can
choose to select that or not
select that, that'll be up to
them. We also have a date
picker. So I'm going to go ahead
and just put in
this date picker right here.
And by default, that will show
you today's date, which you can
then change. And I'm going to go
ahead and change this label to
start dates.
And let's make an end date, one,
two, so end date end date of
each shift. And finally, we're
also going to have a select by a
multiple select, okay, because
we can pick multiple
operations assigned to one user.
So I'm just going to change this
to operations. And let's Harker
the options, the first one is
going to be email ops,
escalation,
just like that. The second one
is going to be security ops,
escalation.
And the third one is going to be
DevOps escalation. So I'm just
going to put dev ops, escalation
just like that. Okay, so now
people can select multiple ones,
which is quite cool. And then
finally, let's have a submit
button. So I'm just gonna get
rid of that and find a button so
that people can submit these
answers. So there we go. And
it's changes to say, submit. So
wonderful, I think that is
looking good. Now let's get to
writing a query for this. So
this is going to be add team
member. So let's change this say
add team member, just make sure
that's the correct resource. And
then we are also going to insert
into so this is where our
playground comes in handy, we're
going to insert into team, it's
going to grab all of that
team member, just paste it in
uncomment that out and just
change the values. So the value
of this will be whatever the
number input two is. So let's
grab the number input to value.
This will be text input two
values, so just get rid of that
input, text input two value, and
then we have text input three
value. So text input three value
will also have email one, so get
rid of that string, input email,
one value.
We also then have the phone
number, which is text input
four. So let's go ahead and put
text input for value. Then we
have the avatar, right, which
will be text input five value.
So let's get rid of that text
input five value. And then we
have a checkbox. So the checkbox
is checkbox one and then we
update one do
To add multi select one, so
that's really easy to remember,
check box value one, this will
be date one.
So date, one value, this will be
date to value.
And this will be the multi
select options or multi, select
one value. Great. So now let's
save this, I'm actually going to
also add some things to do on
success because on success, we
want to, essentially we get the
team, right, so that will happen
onsuccess. And then let's also
have some confetti, because why
not, let's also close the modal.
So we're going to this time
control a component and find the
second modal that we made. So
just scroll down for modal two,
and then we want to close it.
Okay. So that's what we want to
do on success. So now I'm going
to save that and hook up the
Submit button to run that query.
So let's just add an event
handler, control query add team
member. So wonderful, let's try
it out. I'm going to put
employee to to I'm going to put
Beau Carnes and as an email, I'm
just gonna go well, at Free Code
camp.org. And as a phone number,
I'm just going to make this one
up. Okay, just like that.
And as an avatar image, I'm just
going to get one off the
internet Akbar.
Okay, so I'm going to copy the
image address.
And just paste that in, he's not
going to be on call. And let's
put his start date as the 11th.
And the end date as the 14th.
And the operations he's going to
be assigned to?
Well, let's have a look.
I think there's just an email
ops, and security DevOps as
well. So now let's hit submit.
And great bow has been added.
This is looking wonderful.
And finally, let's add a way to
actually delete a team member.
So I'm going to actually do is
write a new query. So let's add
a new query resource query, this
is going to be delete team
number.
Make sure the resource is
correct. And we're going to
delete from
team
where the ID equals the team
table selected row data ID,
right, because we're here, if
we're selecting this one, and we
want to delete it, we just want
to make sure that it's the
correct ID. And that's how we're
going to delete that team
member. So on success, we're, of
course going to have to rerun
the query to get all team
members. So get team and save.
And now we just need to hook up
this button. So let's find that
button. And on click, we want to
run a query. And that query is
to delete a team member.
Okay, so there we go. And Shall
we try it out?
Let's do it. I'm going to delete
this team member.
And wonderful, so that we have
it. And I'm just going to Riad
him. Luckily, all of this is
still here, as I have not
cleared that. I've done that on
purpose, just so it's easy for
us for this tutorial, I'm just
going to hit submit. So there's
both again.
Now for the email composer,
well, it'll be quite nice to
have whoever I'm highlighting,
have their first name show up.
So that's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to you once again, use
the team table, select your data
to get the first name of that
person. Okay, so there we go. It
says Hi, Bo. So this is the
default value of our whole rich
text editor and put a comma
there too. And here as well, we
can show who was sending this
to. So I can use team table
selected or data came out this
time. So great. At the moment,
it's showing Bo, the device
selects myself, of course, this
updates, but this updates to and
then I can write an email and
send it but of course for that
we need to hook this up. Well,
I'm also going to do though, is
whenever we send an email, I'm
going to also send a text
notification. So that's two
resources we need to add. Let's
go ahead and do it. So I'm going
to go to Resources.
And let's just hook up our
Twilio that
We signed up to before. So
please go ahead and find Twilio
on here.
That is Twilio. And I'm going to
do
and is
Twilio.
Let's get the s ID account. So
here is my account s ID.
Let's get the auth token. So
here is my auth token, I will be
deleting this. So please don't
think that it will still work.
If you use it.
I'm just going to select this as
it's not allowing me to update
the IP addresses. And let's test
the connection. So that
connection is successful. And
let's create a resource.
Wonderful. So that is now done,
I'm going to save these changes.
And let's go back to resources.
And this time, I'm going to
create another resource. This
time it's going to be for
emailing, I'm just going to
scroll down to a previous one
that I've made and reconfigure
it. So here are the settings
that you need. However, you do
need to have a Google workspace,
which is a paid workspace for
this to work now. So my Google
workspace credentials are Ania
at code with ania.com. And then
I'm just going to put in my
password for that email. Okay,
so that's what you need to do,
let's test the connection. And
then we're just going to have to
allow less secure apps. So just
go to your admin console. And
I'm just going to search for a
way to control access to less
secure apps. Okay, so that's
here, we go to settings. And
then we go to access and data
control and less secure apps.
And I'm going to allow users to
manage the less secure apps.
Great. So that's for all users
in my company.
And that connection is a
success. So there we go, we have
done it. Great. Now let's go
back to our app is going to get
rid of that. So now let's hook
this up, I'm just going to
create a new query. So let's
create a new query resource
query, this is going to be to
send email.
And this time the resource Well,
it's going to be Gmail.
And the from email
is just going to be from Ania at
code with
ania.com.
And the to email is essentially
going to be whatever we are
selecting right, so the selected
row. So let's go into the team
table, select a row data email,
where you can have a BBC or a
CC, I'm not going to. And this
is just going to say email from
pager duty clone.
And the body. Well, it's just
going to be the body of our rich
text editor. So we're going to
go into rich text editor one and
get the value. Okay, great.
And onsuccess. Let's also just
have some confetti, and save
that. And now let's hook it up
to the Form button. So event
handler on click, we're going to
control the query sent email,
because that is the query that
we are on now. So it's picked
that up. Another thing I want to
do is actually just sent a text
message that we got an email. So
there's gonna be another
resource query send text. And
this time, this is going to be
the resource Twilio that we just
made. So and use Twilio. Okay,
so that's been pre configured
for me. And this is the
operation we need to do. It's a
post request, this is the
endpoint and it's populated my
account Sid, that is good, too.
Well, who we're going to be
sending this to. I'm going to
put in my own phone number in a
bit to test this out. But of
course, usually you would go
into the team table selected row
data and get the phone number
right. So just like that, so
let's go ahead and select
someone. So I am selected so
that should be bringing up my
phone number.
The body I'm just going to put
you have an email notification
from pager duty clan, and from
well from is going to be my
Twilio phone number which is
actually in fact this you can
get it from Twilio as well. If
you don't have a from here,
please go ahead and add a
parameter by clicking here.
Okay, great. So that's what we
want to do and let's just add
some confetti for when this
saves
And I'm just going to attach
that to this bottom two. So send
a text trigger. Okay, so both
those things will happen.
Now,
because of course, this number
doesn't really exist, I am going
to put in my phone number. So
please look away.
And let's say this untested out.
And great. That has worked, I
should have received a text.
So let's check it out. Well,
first off, I'm just going to run
this and see if that has worked.
And let's see bug.
Okay, just to make sure that you
have your email the same one as
you are using in the app. And
that should work. Let's check
the Gmail account. So I'm just
going to sign in and check out
if I got an email. And I did.
Okay, here's my email. Of
course, it does come as HTML. So
we're probably gonna have to
format that a little bit better.
But at least it's sending
something. So there we have it.
We have completed our pager duty
app. Here is in all its glory.
It works. The Twilio API works.
The SMTP API works. We are using
a Postgres database, we can add
incidents, team members, delete
team members, delete incidents.
This is looking glorious. I hope
this tutorial was useful. And I
hope you had fun while learning
and I'll see you soon